Приветствую, с вами Вектор Т13.
И в этом видео я познакомлю вас с технологией, о которой 99% из вас даже еще не слышали.
Знаете ли вы, что такое виртуальные машины?
Наверняка вы знаете, потому что работали с моим антидетектом,
либо же просто пытались запустить какую-нибудь игрушку в виртуальной машине,
для того, чтобы немного почетерить.
Но, помимо всего прочего, виртуальные машины есть еще и в браузере.
И я сейчас говорю не про обычный сэндбокс или что-нибудь такого плана.
А знаете ли вы, что такое джаваскрипт?
Конечно же, знаете.
Как минимум, вы знаете то, что этот язык используется для того,
чтобы веб-ресурсы коммуницировали с пользователем и выполняли различные интересные сложные операции.
И как раз джаваскрипт является источником опасности,
потому что множество технологий определения пользователей построены на базе джаваскрипт.
Если мы вспомним прекрасный браузер Tor,
то там как раз используется расширение NoScript,
которое позволяет полностью блокировать использование джаваскрипт.
Но что, если я вам скажу, что джаваскрипт уже не самый опасный зверь?
А именно, нам навстречу новым технологиям пришла совершенно новая версия джаваскрипта.
То есть это не джаваскрипт, это называется веб-ассембли.
Вот он.
Что такое веб-ассембли?
Если вас интересует, вы можете ознакомиться с этим в интернете.
Это язык программирования, который на текущий момент используется веб-ресурсами.
И данный язык программирования, хоть он и не новый, как нам говорит Википедия,
он появился аж 8 лет назад, в 2018 году.
Сейчас его все больше начинают внедрять.
Плюс ко всему, конечно же, веб-3 и все эти новые технологии,
они хотят перейти с джаваскрипт непосредственно на веб-ассембли.
Потому что веб-ассембли, он выполняется практически настолько же быстро, как и нативный код.
То есть веб-ассембли намного быстрее.
Он компактнее.
И он ближе к железу, чем тот же самый джаваскрипт.
Что он позволяет нам?
Он позволяет компилировать программы.
Веб-ассембли, C++ и основные, и запускать их в браузере практически так же нативно, как и на вашем железе.
Представьте себе, что вы можете в самом браузере запустить, например, условно говоря, тот же самый VirtualBox.
Либо же какое-то другое программное обеспечение.
Можете запустить, например, мессенджер.
Можете запустить кошелек или же что-либо.
Любую другую обычную, самую обычную программу.
Вы можете запустить не на своем ПК, а внутри вашего браузера.
То есть браузер сам создает для вас виртуальную машину внутри себя.
И что самое интересное, эта технология, она уже доступна.
Она уже работает.
И, конечно же, от себя хочу сказать, что я нашел на текущий момент огромное количество отпечатков,
которые можно получить с помощью технологии веб-ассембли.
То есть это совершенно новый мир.
Представьте себе.
Ваши предыдущие отпечатки Canvas, WebGL и вся остальная шляпа, это осталось где-то давным-давно.
В далеком-далеком прошлом.
В аналах истории.
Вот эта технология призвана сейчас полностью изменить вообще весь взгляд на антифрод-системы.
И, конечно же, ей нужно время для того, чтобы это реализовать.
Но кое-что мы можем уже попробовать сейчас.
Прямо сейчас я покажу вам, как работает данный отпечаток.
Итак, я сделал для вас небольшую страничку.
Вы можете с этим кодом ознакомиться.
Страница, повторюсь, данный веб-сайт одностраничный.
Здесь используется всего-навсего 447 строчек кода, включая оформление.
То есть мелочь всего-навсего.
Так вот.
Данный веб-ресурс, данный веб-сайт является чекером отпечатка веб-ассембли.
Что он делает? Как он работает?
Он работает на стыке джаваскрипта и веб-ассембли.
То есть он вызывает функции веб-ассембли из джаваскрипта и зовет джаваскрипт из веб-ассембли.
То есть туда-сюда прогоняет одни и те же скрипты.
Как это работает?
Нажимаем кнопку, точнее, давайте возьмем сейчас наши показатели пока.
И запустим вот этот тест производительности.
И посмотрим сейчас, меняется ли у нас что-то или нет.
Пока проходит этот тест, еще раз продолжаем.
Как он работает?
Из функционала веб-ассембли вызывается джаваскрипт, из джаваскрипта вызывается веб-ассембли.
То есть такой своего рода пинг-понг, туда-сюда, ну в виде моста, назовем его так.
И в частности, знаете к чему это приводит?
Это приводит к идентификации пользователя с погрешностью менее чем 1%.
То есть есть возможность вычислить полностью,
с вероятностью 100% движок браузера.
А значит, что такие параметры как подмена юзер-агента остались просто в прошлом очень-очень далеко.
Можно вычислить использование виртуальной машины.
Хотя там, правда, есть опять же, я как разработчик этих виртуальных машин, знаю какая хитрость там есть.
И можно, в принципе, выделить пиковое количество ресурсов для браузера.
И тогда, в принципе, этот тест можно обойти.
Но для тех, кто не знает это, к сожалению,
можно определить использование виртуальной машины,
а значит, соответственно, VDS.
И, в частности, идентифицировать пользователя благодаря его уникальному отпечатку.
У меня тут чуть с оформлением косяк один вышел,
так что не обращайте внимания.
Итак, благодаря проведению нескольких тестов,
их может быть абсолютно разное количество,
есть возможность определить и отличить.
Одного пользователя от другого с погрешностью всего-навсего менее 1%.
Данная технология, технология получения идентификатора пользователя
благодаря использованию технологии WebAssembly,
была представлена совершенно недавно.
С технической документацией, если вас интересует,
вы можете ознакомиться в прилагаемом документе,
точно так же, как и с примерами кода для выполнения данного веб-ресурса.
Что хочу сказать.
Что хочу сказать конкретно от себя.
Данная технология уже используется на некоторых топовых антифрод-системах.
В частности, системы под названием CyberSource и PerimeterX.
CyberSource уже на финальной стадии использует данную технологию,
PerimeterX только лишь на начальной.
Но, в принципе, из-за ее небольшой ресурсоемкости
и невероятной точности определения,
есть возможность определить использование того или иного браузера
и, опять же, определить использование того или иного аппаратного обеспечения.
Поскольку, несмотря на то, что все равно код, конечно же, выполняется в браузере,
но зависимость от аппаратных ресурсов прямая.
Иными словами, есть возможность, как я и говорил,
отличить использование виртуальной машины, например, от реального ПК,
отличить от другого.
В частности, как я и упоминал,
есть возможность определить использование, например, серверного оборудования.
То есть тогда, когда используются именно серверные CPU.
Поскольку в них происходит немного другой вид вычисления,
как по-простому я не могу это сказать,
алгоритмы вычисления не такие, как на обычных домашних CPU.
И поэтому определить использование сервера не составляет абсолютно никакого труда.
Когда данная технология будет внедрена в массы,
для того, чтобы собрать большое количество статистической информации,
этот отпечаток будет являться топовым среди всех остальных.
То есть вы можете фактически не волноваться о том,
насколько у вас хорошо работает WebGPU, например,
или же что у вас есть такое понятие, как отпечаток WebRTC.
Технология WASM будет являться топовой.
И если в прошлый раз, когда мы говорили по поводу WebGPU,
у нас использование этой технологии намечалось на сентябрь-октябрь 2025 года,
то технология WASM используется уже.
Повторюсь, те ресурсы, которые используют антифрод-систему CyberSource,
одну из топовых антифрод-систем в мире,
ну что говорить, если, например,
Microsoft ее использует.
И, кстати, Microsoft является первым,
кто внедрил данную технологию WASM-фингерпринта,
WebAssembly-фингерпринта, в свои ресурсы.
Поэтому, например, приведу вам пример.
Вы можете эту технологию встретить на странице регистрации Microsoft Partner,
которую мы будем с вами рассматривать дальше в наших уроках.
Но, тем не менее, они таким образом фильтруют боты,
и не разрешают регистрации с виртуальных машин,
либо же с ВПС или удаленных серверов.
Данную технологию впервые начал использовать,
по моей информации, впервые начал использовать Microsoft,
ну и, соответственно, это всего-навсего вопрос времени,
когда мы увидим ее, например, на Амазоне или PayPal.
Поэтому запоминаем, и вы можете ознакомиться с данным тестом,
провести его на своих антидетек-браузерах,
либо же в каких-либо других ресурсах.
Вы можете найти этот тест на сайте DetectExpert,
а также в приложении к данному видеоуроку.
По факту я не буду больше углубляться в то, как работают эти тесты,
потому что это уже больше чистая такая математика.
По-простому, вызов из JavaScript переводится в WebAssembly.
Из WebAssembly вызывается JavaScript.
И так множество раз для того, чтобы определить грамотно
вашу качественную производительность,
и на основании этого идентифицировать вас
и представить вас в виде, в данном случае, отпечатка в хэше SHA-256.
Спасибо за внимание. С вами был VectorT13.